[Music]
Tom and I have been talking about
shooting in Venice for 14 years now
[Music]
one of the reasons I'm drawn to it is it
hadn't been shot in quite the way I
imagined shooting
it's a very difficult location to shoot
there are no vehicles allowed in this
city everything has to be brought in by
boat
been carried to set by hand
it's my first time in Venice
it's mine too
we wanted Venice to have a completely
different feel from the rest of the
movie
and then we made that more challenging
by deciding to shoot a sequence entirely
at night
there's no better place than to shoot a
sequence at the Doge's Palace it's a
signature landmark of Venice we brought
in digital projectors that actually made
the Doge's Palace something of a
character we wanted the building to feel
alive
we staged a party and decided to make it
about the light to color
it's been a long time
great
a chase scene is a signature of every
Mission Impossible
we wanted to do something different this
time
Venice is this Eerie Spooky World with
its narrow alleys and corridors
if you're a stranger here it's very easy
to get lost
this becomes very much a labyrinth in
which the team is lured
there's fights happening simultaneously
each one of the actors is trained in a
different fighting style designed to
express elements of character and
personality
we wanted to really make this a love
letter to Venice and to do it in a way
that it really had never been done
before
much
[Music]